[Music] Conor Berard was 13 days old when cydney
Crosby was drafted number one overall in 2005
Sid the Kid was considered a generational
talented a franchise changer he's more than
lived up to that one of the great players of
all time three times a Stanley Cup champion
tonight Ray Conor Bard begins a career that
he hopes will emulate that of Sydney Crosby
both on and off the ice opening night always
special Ray but really special tonight what
is it about Connor that has him considered to be
a generational Talent before he's even played a
game in this league John I don't think there's
a skill box that Conor Bard does not check one
of the most hyped players to come into the
National Hockey League certainly since Conor
McDavid his Idol is Sydney Crosby his life
will never be the same after tonight's game
because he'll never fold into being a regular
700 guy player in the NHL he will always stand
out there's a ability to shoot the puck that
Brett h in Austin Matthews had Bard and Crosby
about to take the opening face off in a moment
Conor Bard has been dreaming about for a long
time hey Sid welcome back for another season
Conor welcome to the NHL man okay guys it's
show time let's have a great game Telly
southernland with the appropriate start
to this one Chicago with 50 seconds remaining on
the power play Bard Jones Hall it's blocked by
Graves elag go sprawling after it sent back to
the point here's theard and a pad save made by
jar and the other member of that line is gel
here's Crosby to the backand it's stopped by
morazzi and here he comes with some skating room
snaps one and a little bit wide Bard again for
Kaiser back for Bard and that one ricochets into
the near corner now Taylor Hull off Escape rebound
Bard had a great chance the puck is free in
the crease but the whistle stops the play I
know it's his first game and I don't want to
jump into Hyperbole and all that there are not
many players in the NHL less than a handful
that could shoot it like that because when he
drags it into his feet the drag of the stick is
so short it it it doesn't allow the defenseman
Graves to get a stick on it so this one is
released so quickly now Bard comes jumping
in for the rebound and jari makes two stops on
him that kid is going to surprise goalies with
that release before too long and then he drives
to the net and gets a rebound you see the 71
goals last year but Tristan jar turned them away
there they're still on there here's a the guard
shot from a tough angle cars off jari and it
wound up behind the net now kinsky for Bard he
shot it wide his Top Line pressuring again for
Pittsburgh centered by [Applause] Crosby Crosby
Center for gel back for s the kid he [Applause]
scores [Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
under five to go now in the second period Bard
trying to drag it around Carlson Conor Bard
back to Seth Jones Charles out in front hoping
for a tip from Ryan Donado denado 14 goals for
Seattle last year Jones rebound threee for Bard
he winds up with it in the corner back for blasic
Bard Nifty pass for blasic with a lot of room
he put it on that rebound goal Ryan Donado has
Chicago on the board and Conor Bard's got his
first National Hockey League point he'll have
an assist on the pass to blasic the rebound
bounces Odin Ryan dardo 30 goals the last
two years in Seattle the 14 you mentioned last
year is on the doorstep to take the rebound and
put it away the pens are on the ice a long time
they're a little slow there's the pass from Bard
the shot the save the rebound and Donato's cut
the lead in half and Connor Bard in his National
Hockey League debut has a point on the board and
Donato's got his first as a Chicago Blackhawk
yeah let's
[Applause] go he's the youngest NHL player
to get a point in a season opener in 10 years
Alexander barov and Nathan McKinnon
both in October of 2013 here's Bard
and he shot it right into the midsection of
jari maybe at some point they're gonna have
to get somebody on his line that can take
face offs but this is such an W one there
you go on Q bedard's got his first win
against Crosby man they're hard to play
against Bard back it goes and it's snatched out
of the air his whole family was worried about
him making the team Luke Richardson told us his
parents were going to get an apartment and so we
don't want to be premature we're going to wait
to make sure he makes it Luke Richard said he's
going to make the team and Richardson Bard and the
Hawks an impressive win on opening night back stop
by morzak who was outstanding stopped 38 out of
40 shots Ryan denado got the scoring started as
they rallied from a two nothing deficit with
four straight to Win 4 to2 and Bard's debut